bonjour sa fait donc exactement trois
mois qu'on n'a pas fait de castet sur
cette chaîne donc je reviens aujourd'hui
avec un nouveau casse tête et il ya des
petits trucs à dire ça ça s'appelle le
coffret de gouvernail ou un truc comme
ça le gouvernail de la mort face à sent
pas bon parce que ça sent le truc
exponentielle mais ça on va y revenir et
la petite surprise c'est que voilà on
voulait faire un casse tête nous restait
lui qu'on avait commandé avec loïc on
n'avait pas encore fait sauf que
aujourd'hui faut quand même savoir thé
pour remettre les choses en place un
petit peu c'est que je rentre de tourner
n'est ce pas lui qui est gt ou tous
d'aller à tahiti donc j'ai douze heures
de décalage horaire je me suis enrhumé
dans l'avion et je vais faire mais
pourquoi on fait ça pour quoi pourquoi
pas correct pour info cette vidéo sera
sponsorisé par un jeu mobile ou quoi
mais fait déjà tant pis
et pourquoi pas parce que ses sponsors
aussi qui permettent de financer les
mentalisme dans la rue ou les jeux des
bruits david de six personnes ce genre
de grosses vidéos que vous connaissez et
qui n'ont pas de sponsors parce que je
pense aux avants parce qu'on est malin
on est malin bref donc vous aurez accès
à tout à l'heure
et c'est parti
[Musique]
m
i comme je vous l'annonçais il ya
quelques secondes cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par le jeu réd le jeu que
vous connaissez peut-être et si vous
connaissez pas vous allez connaître ce
jeu incroyable au graphisme délirant
n'est ce pas loïc mais peut-être que
vous connaissez déjà parce qu'on a on
est quand même à 15 millions de
téléchargements en six mois de ce jeu
complètement gratuit c'est un jeu en
mode épique dark fantasy où vous allez
vous créer une collection de champion il
ya à peu près 400 champions que vous
pouvez personnaliser et qui stomisés et
que vous allez envoyer combattre le
principe de la campagne est très bien
avec un bon storytelling aussi bon que
les graphismes du jeu mais vous pouvez
aussi combattre en arène en mode pvp
vous pouvez faire des raids avec votre
propre clan que vous allez composer avec
vos propres champions et si des fois
voulu avancer peinard vous mettez en
auto et vous pouvez faire autre chose à
côté pendant que le champion phoques en
train de déboîter les autres chaque
semaine il y à des tournois il ya des
événements il ya plein de mise à jour
aussi qui sont annoncés à l'avancé un
jeu qui vis un jeu qui évolue et puis je
vous avoue quand même que j'aime bien
les jeux de rpg surtout quand on peut
personnaliser et là de créer ses propres
ses propres titres de champion en allant
piocher dans les sept factions qui
existe et qu'on puisse personnaliser
tout ça j'aime bien
vous avez évidemment un lien pour
télécharger le jeu dans la description
ce lien vous donnera deux bonus déjà
vous allez avoir cinquante mille de
silver dès le départ donc sa bague merci
ça fait toujours plaisir et surtout vous
allez avoir un champion épique gratuit
au bout du septième jour avec le l'union
layher rewards c'est accent anglais vous
est offert par fabien olicard
télécharger red piano de gains qui en
descriptions ou que j'ai mis aussi en
commentaire épinglés merci à eux 2
sponsorisé cette vidéo mais au delà en
fait ça aide la chaîne et donc ça aide à
sponsoriser les vidéos que vous aimez
vous téléchargez c'est gratuit et vous
tester le jeu
voilà c'est tout avec son pote minutes
de bonus au départ que demande le peuple
et puis maintenant on va se faire un bon
raid pour se casser la tête sur le sur
le gouvernail c'est autre chose c'est
parti pour le casse tête
je le sens moyen loïc qui se casse tête
je te jure que je me sens moyen c'est en
fait c'est aussi pour ça qu'il était
dans la réserve depuis un petit moment
parce que je le sens moyen difficulté 6
sur 6 si vous êtes intéressé par ce qu
est l je vous mets un lien dans la
description comme d'habitude vers une
page où vous pouvez de l'acquérir et sur
ma
aschens secondaire machine flocons vers
vous aurez la version non montée ce
quartier d'être appliquée et comme je
suis très fatigué aujourd'hui j'ai
maintenu mes lunettes test en
perspective pour que tu te grattes le
téton quand je te parle falloir faire un
genre qui mettrait une go pro ici que
les gens puissent te voir tout le temps
et voir ce que je vois et a vu comment
on prend milan alors est ce que c'est
vraiment charlot y compris ce qu'est
aujourd'hui j'ai dû mettre une petite
laine alors le gouvernail est composé
comme suit d'un écrou sur un socle de
bois d'un pourtour tourner ça des et il
semble bien que tout va se passer sur le
dessus pourquoi tu regarde toujours
offert bien ça me stresse hashtag écran
de retour peut-être et donc il ya cette
pièce là qui est amovible
n'est ce pas mais ici il ya les trucs
marron qui ont un petit péteux you say
is war au bout qui peuvent s'enfoncer
ici et je sens bien qu'il faut que
j'attende ça je comprends pas trop le
but pour l'instant mais je me dis si ça
ça tourne
et ça ça se déboîte un peu comme ça il
faut faire le tour
quoi qu'on retombe de dans le champ
ok on va se tester ça comment ça marche
là si je veux le tourner ici il faut que
je te tire sa dose est possible ce qui
me permet de le tourner là mais ensuite
il rentre en buter contre le petit bout
de bois qui est ici donc il faudrait que
je le bes et pour le bc les ennuis
commencent
et ça commence les ennuis ou quoi merci
sympathique intervention en fait c'est
vraiment ma vraie difficulté de ce casse
tête c'est de pas tant bien comprendre
que ça comme moi tu fonctionnes ses
combats avec d'accord at home et là est
ce que lui je peux leur hockey
donc là on peut commencer à temps et
après la salle voûtée mais ça va buter
contre eux qui avaient contredit
je pense qu'il va falloir faire pas mal
d'allers retours
j'ai essayé de tout libérer mais je sais
pas tellement pourquoi on rêve bush
pourrait très bien aller dans ce sens là
on remarque c'est pareil pourquoi pas
parce que là je me semble ok je continue
dans ce sens pas pourquoi ça me paraît
plus logique là qu'à la fin du casse
tête on apprend que non en fait depuis
le départ il fait des tournées dans
l'autre sens donc là lui faudra qu'ils
soient roms étaient un petit peu pour
qu'ils soient remontés avec lui son rôle
à là ça va être galère
attention les problèmes comme je
comprends déjà pas ce qui bloque lui
quoi qu'il arrive ce petit bout là ne
peut pas passer là parce que lui est
trop haut
donc pour le bc il faut je désenclave
celui ci qui enclavé à cause de lui
soit mais du coup lui cette enclave et
je dis donc là est ce que je peux leur
montée plus non
ok là je peux continuer à tourner ok là
j'arrive ici est donc là je vais avoir
la même problématique donc à la limite
je peux leur remontée pour remonter il
faut que je désenclave lui c'est sans
arrêt à huawei
sinon vous pouvez aller jusque là oui
bah oui bien sûr ça va jusqu'à lui est
ce que 1 mais là je peux pas le coup
c'est lui vas-y ça va être chaud non moi
ça m'arrange pas à cette histoire
les petits amis de la forêt a le droit
de forcer un sur les castes est comme ça
loïc 1 mais qu'il est trop corpo à
tanger peut-être essayé de partir dans
l'autre sens alors j'annule j'allume
j'annule on efface on effacer comme ça
des petits qui disait phase espace
j'efface j'efface j'annule pour aller
dans ce sens là il faudrait que je
baisse lui au bc lui il est enclavé de
ce côté là tout est impliqué en
permanence ça en fait quelque chose
parce que s'il a du jeu qui force comme
un putois aussi
bon on repart sur la gauche l'a donc
donc ici monsieur décide de bloquer pour
le débloquer je descende avant pour le
des clips et comme ça vaut descendre lui
est arrivé là ok ok je comprends la
logique mais je ne vais pas vous mentir
je la comprends moyens quand même c'est
pas c'est pas si clair que ce à quoi je
pourrais jamais me remettre dedans ça
m'arrange pas parce que lui quoiqu'il
ait gelé désenclave et pour le
désenclaver lui donc pour pouvoir le
remonter
il faudrait que lui c'est cette
alternance là je la remets dedans mais
donnant c'est beaucoup trop bas il n'y a
rien que je peux bouger en entendant ça
on est d'accord que tout est intrigué on
a d'accord qu'il n'est pas dans cochon
n'a point d'encoches que je me délier au
pire il faudra que toutes les petites
vis là elle soit extérieur mais plus ça
va moi ça me parait jouable en imposant
que ça se dévissent comme la coupe la
coupe davis de tennis à bazas oui c'est
pour ça que tu arrives et moi je sors
des trucs je sais même pas en fait doux
doux de quel monde vient cette blague
ils ont des fois des encoches alloue un
peu des fois pas où ils ont toujours le
même temps ils ont toujours des
formulations donc il ya que quand c'est
enfoncer enfoncé qu'on peut mettre sympa
donc si j'enfonce fort titre je peux la
mettre là tu trop subi quel est mon
intérêt
mon intérêt de libérer celle qui a ici
j'essaie de trouver une logique parce
que tant que j'aurai pas la logique je
pourrais pas le résoudre en fait il
n'est pas comme les autres
en attentant jan il ya une languette qui
est complètement différente des autres
c'est celle ci est ce que tout viendra
d'elle est ce que mon but ce serait pas
d'emmener ce cercle là ici puisque c'est
à peu près ce que cherchait à faire
depuis le départ mais j'avais même pas
fait gaffe pour vous dire si je suis
radié que cette langue est là l apal
même arrondi que les autres
le gouvernail et à la pas les mêmes
encoches a priori l'a4 encoches les
hôtes en en deux à droite et l'espèce de
trucs chelous ici pourquoi ce truc
chelou il peut remonter derrière ce
genre vraiment essayé avec lui est ce
que à [ __ ] mais oui ça change tout ça
je n'ai pas du tout compris regardez là
je sais pas si vous voyez bien la forme
je vous la faire voir ici sur cette
fente la waic ça ça fait un trou une
encoche sûr et ça ça remonte et du coup
on peut mettre un truc comme ça et on
peut leur descendre quand même et ça je
vais pas vous mentir je l'avais pas
encore compris qu'ils devraient pouvoir
changer mes problèmes parce que là il ya
que ça des problèmes ok là je suis allé
plus loin que je n'ai jamais été look
lagesse bout de bois qui va bloquer avec
le bitonio donc du coup il faut que je
puisse leur descente pour le redescendre
il faut que ça je le remonte il faut que
je désenclave lui pour le désenclaver
faut que je remonte lui pour que je
remonte lui il faut que lui soient là
dedans pour qu'il soit là dedans il faut
que je fasse comme ça ensuite comme ça à
qui permet de faire ça la claque hockey
qui nous permettra de faire ça voilà là
là là ça vous rappelle rien ça où tout
rentrer en application les uns avec les
autres
ok c'est pas mal c'est pas mal parce que
ça avant cela a mis la vie mais schepp a
few habile au bo
loïc si tu veux mettre une petite
accélération
je suis preneur accélération dont il
n'ira jamais la musique à personne en
france
[Musique]
à
mon but c'est de descendre lwin tuer je
met un petit pot ce type
fabien post-it masters donc mon but
c'est de descendre celui là il ya un
petit truc exponentielle que je ne
saisis pas bien mais il n'y a pas cru
non mais c'est pas possible aussi un
moment donné ok donc lui gelé baissé on
se rappelle on se rappelle que c'est un
avide de le baisser je les baisser
maintenant il faut que je puisse
repasser ce circuit là pour voter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok ok pour lui benouza restes de corps
en admettant encore une fois que ce soit
la bonne solution
il nous reste c'est de la abc ok bon ben
maintenant c'est lui qui bloque
j'ai bien fait de mettre le petit
post-it parce que ça m'aide vraiment à
savoir où j'en suis peut-être gens
vraiment on en est au même point ster
que maintenant je veux blesser le bidon
pour baisser lui faudrait que lui soit
dans lui mais pour que lui soit dans lui
faudrait que je puisse pousser lui donc
que lui soit dans lui donc qu'il faut
que je puisse pousser by donc que lui
soit dans lui et ses excès des rats quoi
ah ah
prenons quelques secondes ensemble pour
discuter je m'appelle fabien licka je ne
veux pas que des castes et sur cette
chaîne je fais énormément de choses je
parle de mental de mentalisme abonnez
vous à cette chaîne via le bouton
abonnez vous juste ici et laisser un
like de soutien à cette vidéo ah si
peut-être aurais-je le courage de
continuer les casse tête de plus en plus
compliqué voilà oui vous pouvez
également gagner ce casse-tête
précisément sur la page instagram qui
s'affiche juste ici d'une manière
élastique pour que le week en chine un
peu au montage vous voulez revoir cette
élasticité
mais regardez je les tire encore plus
comme ça il ne peut pas reprendre le
même pré cette voie là laïque et abonnez
vous je vous laisse quelques instants
pour ça quelques instants à vous étiez
déjà abonnées activer la cloche ne ratez
jamais aucune sortie merci
reprenons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok pour lui il reste donc plus que celui
ci j'ai pas qu'en débutant à temps je
suis dessus tu sais où catholiques au
lavage trois quarts d'heure déjà [ __ ]
ça c'est ce qu'ils regardent la version
non montées doivent se régaler vu à quel
point je ne parle pas pour ne pas me
perdre dans ma tête je ne me reste plus
que celui ci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok donc il nous reste que sept vit cela
comme vous pouvez le constater il ne
reste que 7 bis cela n'est pas encore
poussé là tout le reste est bon celle-ci
non mais c'est pas grave puisque l apal
bitonio clac clac
[Musique]
attends faux pas je leur montre ce qui
se passe là bas mais non ça je suis pas
d'accord on est bien mais je les tire et
je les tire est ok ok on se calme
imposer mm tout a été fait en exactement
55 minutes ambiant c'est donc une
liberté de mouvement complète de ce truc
là
et le truc que je veux dit depuis le
départ je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut
débloquer je ne sais pas tellement
pourquoi j'ai l'impression que ça se
dévissent ou pas si un [ __ ] si c'est
bon c'est ça j'ai tellement peur que ce
soit pas ça attends je dévisse
complètement
une fois que j'ai dévisser complètement
je peux pas que jusqu'à ce tour
non je peux pas si je peux le hic j'ai
peur si c'est vrai c'est ça
ah ouais d'accord il est tellement
collait tellement j'ai forcé dessus j'ai
trop appuyé sur le bois tu crois un
temps mais je ne sais pas si je viens de
le réussir six jeunes de casser oui oui
oui
ouais c'est un casse-tête rondement mené
à sa race
il est beaucoup trop chaud bon tu sais
quoi je vais leur faire vite que dans
l'autre sens mais hors caméra j'espère
que ce 4 steve de type casse tête bien
sûr vous a plu
en vrai il est cool à faire mais il en
fait il est bien cool mais il est bien
bien chiant on va pas se mentir est
extrêmement casse couilles en fait c'est
ça c'était une phrase à la mode pendant
un temps on va pas se mentir on aime
bien se sentir menacé
enfin on va pas se mentir on remercie on
remercie pleinement notre notre sponsor
du jour à savoir le jeu réd dont vous
trouvez un lien dans la description vous
avez tous le téléchargement est tout ce
que tu faisais leur reste complètement
vrai merci à eux de soutenir la création
bien ce sponso qui permet de financer
les vidéos que vous aimez bien je pense
aussi que j'aime bien celle ci quand
même parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment besoin
de prendre ça pour ça l'important
mais par contre pour les autres alors
que les autres on en a pas abonnez vous
like et la vidéo à très bientôt
ciao